[Applause]
a California man is shot and killed by
sheriff's deputies after approaching
them with a gun and repeatedly calling
for them to shoot himself
the Los Angeles County Sheriff's
Department released body camera video
from the deadly shooting that happened
on January 26th as part of the Operation
Safe Streets Bureau sheriff's deputies
were working to serve a search and
arrest warrant in the city of Maywood to
start detectives found a man uninvolved
with a search warrant sitting on the
front porch
hello everybody
okay it's okay come right over here
what's your name Jonathan all right
Jonathan come right over here
come this way come up this way look it's
not you okay you're not in trouble
yeah
officials say the man was cooperative
and only briefly detained so you're not
in any trouble okay
listen listen relax okay
after that body camera video shows
sheriff's deputies at the side door of
the home man
um Lopez
who else is here ma'am
the woman told officials her husband 70
year old Miguel Lopez was still inside
meanwhile separate sheriff's deputies
knock on the home's front door
County Sheriffs I know
the county sheriffs open the door Lopez
approaches the front door but refuses to
come outside
yeah dogs in there what Sheriff's
Department dude open the door I hear you
he looks like we'll make contact over
here however he's an Open Door
I need you to step out we have a search
warranty
I go out
I want to see you move back I'm going
out
body camera video shows officials
explaining they have a search warrant
and do not plan on hurting Lopez
we have a search warrant
open the door dude open the door and let
me see your hands oh uh
just open the door
your wife is on the side buddy I know
we've been calling you I say a step back
I'm going out okay nobody's gonna hurt
you okay
go to the other door go to the other
side I'm not going all the door
over here right now for more than a
minute sheriff's deputies try to
convince Lopez to exit the home I'm not
going upside you don't step back
that clear sir
we don't want to hurt anybody you're not
in trouble it's not even about you we
already explained it to your wife like
about what why we're here why tell step
out and I'll tell you no I'm not going
okay after that Lopez walks away from
the front door can you see his hands no
I can't see anything
soon sheriff's deputies at the front
door hear a commotion coming from the
side door
[Applause]
you got a gun
nobody
drop the gun body camera video from
officials at the side door shows Lopez
approaching the door armed with a
handgun investigators later determined
it was a 357 caliber revolver
put the gun away Lopez continues to
approach sheriff's deputies and does not
drop the weapon instead he reaches for
one of the detective's guns when Lopez
points his weapon at officials two
sheriff's deputies opened fire Sheriff
Department
fuck
I don't think nobody wants directions
Los Angeles County paramedics performed
life-saving measures but Lopez was
pronounced dead on the scene right now
the shooting is still under
investigation by the Los Angeles County
Sheriff's Department a separate review
of the shooting is being conducted by
the Los Angeles County District
Attorney's Office reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie